let me tell you something you have to be
a specific type of dumbass to try to eat
four pounds of Vietnamese noodles
I have eaten a lot of things in my life
okay I've eaten a box and a half of
Costco pizza I've eaten a burrito the
size of my arm old Apache breaking
bricks 24 tacos in one sitting a baby
draft my god these agencies everything
and of course before I left I didn't go
by myself I don't know with my crew my
backbone so this is the morning of and
we are all on our way to the fun
challenge that's my wife yeah oh yeah
you're recording yes I am recording huh
hi you take a picture and of course
along the way there was just some random
footage of Mia recording some stupid
things like check this out I thought
this was a funniest thing in the world
yeah she this lady had the oh you just
got to watch it yeah that's it that's a
no best a look at that it's better than
mine we'll do the haircut apparently
before you even start to eat the food
you have to sign a death waiver that
basically says you're done son like
you're dead if you die eating the food
too bad sucker so of course I took the
time to read it very carefully the
doctors or the documents or the
documentation the documents are
documented properly the documents
I got the document we documented it's
funny because right after I ate the food
or I stopped when I looked at it at
first I really think it was that bad so
we started off with you know me being
really copy system home put your bowl
next kids for comparison
I think I see Jesus do these black
I'm thinking about it I guess up is
staring at me
you're gonna cry 17 minutes another one
look fine
my people I just can't like not because
yeah nothing look like I don't want you
I really want to do you don't know that
I want that ball I haven't left like
this Facebook but also knows exactly
you're so close let's go show them the
flag again honey nothing happens oh yeah
last minute win boys let's go don't you
just go
sixteen minutes
here we go like a view like the view